22 winners all underage 20 $100,000 to
drop out of school and pursue our dreams
this is Team technorati
this is n2 45 it's home to a lot of
space scientists astrobiologists and
some astrophysicists I used to work in
this office and between break times at
UC Berkeley I'm using artifact in here
is the Star Trek poster right over there
find it very inspirational when I'm
working in the depths of code trying to
get the modeling coefficients just right
hey Chris hey I'm Chris McKay I'm a
planetary scientist here at NASA Ames
Research Center do you have enough
material physical sample to do the
experiment plenty i've got about seven
transects where if each transect as
about 10 to 15 samples we discussed the
samples that I collected in French
Polynesia last semester we're now
working on genetic analysis to see
what's related to what in these rocks
that I collected from the intertidal
zone from my perspective Rebecca is at a
decision point she's clearly got the
capability to do science but she's also
entrepreneurial she could really be a
role model for other women as to what
what possibilities are open science is
something you can do or starting tech
companies is something you can do
through the Tal fellowship I now have
the time to pursue my research interests
as well as my company idea honeybadger
aerospace intends to do
pre-qualification of small satellites in
space before they get to space
today right now we're going to be
introduced to moon Express which is
aspiring to put the very first
commercial private robotic spacecraft on
the surface of the Moon and by doing so
to change the definition of what is
possible everything that we care about
fight about and find precious on earth
energy resources land territory it's all
available in infinite quantities in
space the first kids born today will be
looking up and seeing lights on the moon
so as we create space colonies and we
learn to live on other worlds we're not
only increasing our survivability as a
species but we're replicating our bases
here on planet Earth which is so far
only constrained to one potential point
of failure right the dinosaurs didn't
have a space program sure go ahead
how do you plan about terraforming I
love the idea of terraforming and you
know I've kind of grown up with the idea
of you know someday we're going to
terraform Mars but the magnetic field is
such that the particles flying off the
Sun strip off the atmosphere over time
causing a set of collisions that removes
the atmosphere so what if instead we
actually restarted the Dynamo that might
be a great idea of how we do that
we use this facility to develop our own
engineering tests of our first concept
of our lunar landers we wanted to have a
scalable system so we could start small
right and scale it without redesigning
entire thing as the market responded so
what we came up with was this spacecraft
design we could get all the way from
Earth orbit to the surface of the Moon
just with this little guy right here at
Moon X I really learned and saw
firsthand the need to have this kind of
pre-qualification go on before we send
something into space so you can be able
to tell the person who's carrying your
payload whether it will be safe or not
we've given you a kind of an orientation
su and moon express we showed you the
hover test facility we saw the mock-up
lander now you're gonna meet some of the
really important people behind the
vision that's making it happen well let
me introduce Andy alter and buzzes son
our president Andy
the opportunity to come here and
actually participate in sending
spacecraft to the moon and developing
the moon commercially it is just a dream
come true
and I brought Andrew Jake and Mike to
meet with you as kind of a sample of the
younger generation of Engineers that are
20-somethings at the same bit age
basically as the 20-somethings who
created the Apollo program I'm an
electrical engineer here we're can
avionics Department I graduated from the
University of Michigan worked on cube
SATs there for three years and I've been
working up here working on some pretty
amazing things I dropped out after my
sophomore year of college when I was 20
years old to come work here because I
figured you know I I wasn't going to get
this opportunity when I graduated we all
have stories about how our parents
reacted to dropping out of high school
college I'm curious to hear how your
parents felt about you
my mom was incredibly surprised when I
brought it up of all the kids that she
knew I wouldn't be the one to drop out
of school but given given the
opportunity she was pretty supportive of
it it's all about people in the
relationships you build and you can do
amazing things I know some of you are
space nerds and you're gonna be seeing
you again I know so I've had the
privilege of meeting new friends and new
amazing people now isn't it beautiful
all right so let's change the world it's
really cool to see the old space side in
the new space side working together
there's crazy things that happen in the
space environment you can't really
prepare for but you've got to try to
prepare for it yeah what if you could
test it in space before you get into
space I'd be awesome company I'm
pitching is actually
Badger aerospace and ironically this is
exactly what we're trying to look really
yeah I thought to talk to you more about
especially about the practice of being
an engineer at such a company and I'm
looking at starting hiring over the next
few months in particular I can go and
run it grab a notepad or something give
you my email how many times do you guys
get to use Houston we have a problem
there's too many problems a good time
let's go to the moon
good point up let's really good tune in
for the next episode of teen technorati
when Thomas shares his plans to cure
cancer and be sure to subscribe to the
wired Channel